if you consider an animal cell to be a
factory then the plasma membrane of the
cell is just like the boundary wall of
the factory now every factory has their
own gate by which people can go in and
go out the workers the workers can go in
or out just like the factory the cell
membrane also has specific ion channels
transporters etc which can regulate the
movement of ions and other particles
across the membrane
now these proteins which are present in
the plasma membrane of the cells could
be of different kind they could be
receptors ion channels some gtp is
helping him some cell signaling role ion
pumps or even membrane bound enzymes so
each of these proteins might have very
different role now according to fluid
mosaic model the plasma membrane is a
sea of new lipids on which there are
some islands floating which are
basically the membrane proteins so the
fluid mosaic model state that the
membrane is mostly lipid and membrane
has two bilayers so membrane has a
phospholipid bilayer right so the basic
composition of the membrane is nothing
but the phospholipids phospholipids at
the chunk of the membrane so the
phospholipids has a hydrophobic head a
hydrophilic head and hydrophobic tail in
the hydrophobic tail there are basically
it is composed of fatty acid tails
whereas the hydrophilic head has
glycerol and specific polarized group
which is basically charged and that is
why it is the head of the phospholipid
is charged and it loves water now if we
look at the structure in details so the
common group the the head group could be
like different for example saving
choline or eternal mind
and based on which of the head group is
present the phospholipid would be termed
differently for example if the head
group is serum it is phosphatidylserine
or if the head group is cooling it is
phosphatidylcholine
sometimes instead of glycerol another
kind of alcohol is present which is
called sphingosine and the lipid
containing that the phospholipid
containing sphingosine is known as Rima
myelin myelin is also abundant
phospholipid in present in the membranes
now if we talk about the distribution of
phospholipids in different organelles
inside the cell we would see a huge
heterogeneity for example if we compare
ER versus call D the membrane
composition would be very different and
scientists still try to understand what
is the significance behind that forget
about the organelles if we just talk
about the inner leaflet of the membrane
versus the outer leaflet of the membrane
there is also heterogeneity in terms of
distribution of the phospholipids
for example phosphatidyl ethanolamine
is mostly present in the internal site
or the cytosolic site whereas hospital
cooling is prevalently present in the
outer side I mean the extracellular side
so this distribution heterogeneity is
very important because and and sometimes
looking at the distribution people can
understand that how healthy our cell is
because in case of apoptosis Hospital
eternal mind goes outside in the outer
leaflet than the inner leaflet so these
distribution has defined inner meaning
to towards cell physiology
now the membrane lipids are actually not
rigid
they are fluid just like you can see
they're always moving and they are like
getting disorganized or reorganized this
kind of dynamics is happening all the
time and even the membrane fluids and
membrane proteins are actually also not
static they are also moving all across
the membrane so first of all we should
ask that what type of motion does they
exhibit
so among they can their motion can be
classified into three sub categories for
example first is lateral motion that a
particularly deep it can
actually diffuse all across the membrane
second a particularly lipid can rotate
across a specific axis giving a
rotational motion
there could be transpiler flip-flop
movement as well and sometimes these
motions are spontaneous and sometimes
these motions are guided so we talked
about some guided motion so first of all
some time the lipid from the outer
leaflet can be quickly transformed to
the inner leaflet and this can happen
spontaneously as well but sometimes with
the help of an enzyme known as flippers
this reaction is very fast and the lipid
from the outer leaflet get transported
to the inner leaflet or flipped towards
the inner leaflet opposite to it is
performed by the enzymes Phillipines by
which the phospholipids in the inner
leaflet moves toward the other side this
two type of movement can happen
simultaneously and this is triggered by
an enzyme scramble is which can flip
them in opposite direction at the same
time so these enzymes help in lipid
movement and with the enzyme the rate of
the reaction is wave fast now we should
also understand that what are the
factors that can maintain membrane
fluidity so first of them is cholesterol
the amount of cholesterol which is
present in the membrane determines how
fluid or rigid it would be so
cholesterol work like a dynamic so in
lower concentration cholesterol increase
the membrane rigidity but as it's
surprising that at higher concentration
cholesterol increases the membrane
fluidity
so cholesterol is a steroid which is
also synthesized in the cytoplasm and by
the enzyme and the key enzymes are
present in the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum we'll be talking about that
now cholesterol has key parts it has a
non-polar height
garble Intel it has a rigid steroid
structure and a polar group so it can
easily fit in in between the bilayer in
between the phospholipid residues now
the phospholipid residues are kind of
glued by cholesterol and thereby their
movement is kind of restricted so apart
from cholesterol the type of the
phospholipid tail it has it also impinge
on the fluidity factor for example if
the phospholipid bilayer has mostly
saturated hydrocarbon moiety then the
membrane would be more rigid and more
organized but if a membrane is a mixture
of saturated and unsaturated
phospholipids then there would be kink
in the unsaturated phospholipids and due
to that the membrane would be more
dynamic and fluid whereas a membrane
which doesn't have these unsaturated
phospholipids would be less fluid so
depending upon the saturation of the
phospholipids itself the membrane
fluidity could be different and memory
fluidity also depends upon temperature
and terms of other factors which which
we would be talking in other video now
phospholipid biosynthesis takes place in
the smooth endoplasmic reticulum because
we have to understand that how the
phospholipid is synthesized at the first
place so we know that inside the cell in
size plus glucose get converted to
acetyl Kawai and a satiric away order
get converted to fatty acyl cooing this
fatty acyl Kawai along with glycerol
3-phosphate on the surface of a smooth
endoplasmic reticulum can get converted
to phosphatidic acid by the help of the
enzyme acyl transferase now this
phosphatidic acid is one of the key
component for phospholipid biosynthesis
phosphoric acid by the help of the
enzyme phosphatase get converted to die
glycerol now the diacyl glycerol can be
further processed by fossil transferase
enzyme to attach a head group on that
for example a cooling forceful
transferase would attach a cooling group
to the diacyl glycerol and it would firm
phosphatidyl cooling which is a key
phospholipid present in the outer
leaflet of the membrane
similarly the head group could attach
could be different for example seven or
eight Eleanore mine and depending upon
that these phospholipid would be also
different now the rate limiting step of
cholesterol biosynthesis also takes
place in the smooth endoplasmic
reticulum smooth endoplasmic reticulum
it would be considered as a hub of
membrane lipid biosynthesis both
cholesterol and both the phospholipid
cells now in case of cholesterol the
main component is as it was telco a and
acetyl CoA which condense to form h mg
quai now hmg-coa gets reduced to Mable
on it by the help of the enzyme h mg
query darkness and this step is
considered to be the rate limiting step
in the cholesterol biosynthesis pathway
and that is triggered by smooth
endoplasmic reticulum itself and after a
series of pathway Neverland it get
converted to cholesterol and cholesterol
could either be incorporated into the
membrane or cholesterol could be used as
a raw material to create a steroid
steroid hormones
so that is why muth endoplasmic
reticulum is super important for plasma
membrane biogenesis itself now if we
talk about different types of cell the
cell membrane identity chemically might
look similar
for example we come to consider
epithelial cell versus a neuronal cell
the composition of the membrane is
mostly similar because it has
phospholipids proteins etc but sometimes
the membrane could separate charge for
example a neurons membrane is charged
whereas a normal cell membrane is
uncharged and these this has very
different meaning and the way the
neurons membrane is charged
use by restriction of specific ionic
flow by sodium potassium ATPase and
specific other voltage-gated ion
channels and that is how membrane
potential is generated in the neuron now
apart from that we talked about lipid
rafts the lipid rafts a specific domains
on the membrane here we talk about a B
cell which produce antibody and try to
come back infection right and B cell
surface has P cell receptor when the B
cell is not encountering or engaging
into immune reaction its receptor are
kind of dispersed away in the membrane
but when it encounters a pathogen or it
detects antigen the P cell receptors
come closing the membrane in a micro
domain known as lipid raft and this is a
rich this lipid raft in the site for
talking of many signaling molecules and
thereby signaling pathways could be
triggered inside the cell so in that
context lipid rafts are super important
in terms of cell signaling and we would
be talking about lipid rafts in a whole
different video so for now it's just an
overview of cell membrane I hope you
enjoyed this video if you liked this
video give me a quick thumbs up don't
forget lecture thank you